Bitcoin is the ultimate form of Freedom
it's nothing like a central bank digital
currency a central bank digital currency
or a cbdc is going to be entirely in the
control of your government and don't be
fooled they'll sell it to you like it's
far more safe safer than Bitcoin less
volatile all this rubbish they're going
to sell to you it's not true Bitcoin is
decentralized which means there's no CEO
there's no centralized Authority there's
no one individual which is setting the
agenda this is why I'm a massive
proponent for Bitcoin because regardless
of what your opinion is nobody's going
to confiscate your Bitcoin with the
Central Bank digital currency if you go
over your carbon allowance or if you say
the wrong thing on social media you
don't even need to pay a fine they'll
just take it from you and they can do
this because it's entirely in the
control of the Central Bank and in the
control of the likes of those at the
world economic forum